yeah I don't know I'm sorry
comfortable high reject nation I'm Greg
Alba what's your name marriages bring it
all back Sally's back we go all the way
back yeah spider-man no yeah hey Sally
I'm glad you're here because this is a
highly requested video this video came
out a while ago it's Tom Hollands rude
fans insult sebastian stan and anthony
mackie shuts them dumbasses down to talk
to them and you insult them bunch of
idiots at a freaking critic crowd dumb
asses just do it like a YouTube
commentator keep it there guys I want to
give a shout out to a man named Eric
Oliver he's been one of our highest
pledges on patreon for quite some time
now
and this guy actually works for fandom
wiki fandom and stuff so he knows a
thing or two about being unreasonably
hasty towards people in the geek
community towards these people who star
in Marvel movies he knows what it's like
to be a total a-hole about it because he
does fandom and you know what fan can be
a little bit mean but Eric Oliver is a
nice freakin dude I love you buddy I
can't wait to hang out with you and when
John and I go to San Francisco you best
believe we are cuddling with each other
because that's what you get on patreon
cuddle time yeah not even my own
girlfriend gets that okay where's her
Eric you know
[Music]
topher grace yeah anyway let's watch
this voyage of the Trojans
got everybody you got the two parter
well done what are your names everyone
give it up for Jamy what's your name
everyone give it up please take it away
ladies you're gonna bring us home and us
well you just shot the Winter Soldier in
the face have a good time on the
internet tonight how do you know who he
he's posting pictures of him and his dog
yes he's just hanging out at home what
is your baby I'm an adult
[Laughter]
I follow no man just so you know write
it down take a picture to eat that [ __ ]
I follow no I don't know to turn friends
I know to turn tight what stuff get
tight let me see what your friend little
bit you would get what did your friend
say tell us what your friends say you
and your friends are
[Music]
[Music]
and the word said this compliment came
since the idea of the word question is
lost on you two over here young lady
[Music]
hayseed not with more videos like this
click here well thank you for putting
that video together whoever you are that
it was one awkward ass confrontation
right there what's interesting is I
thought tom was just gonna be laughing
he seemed genuinely uncomfortable about
the whole thing it made it more awkward
if you didn't find it funny it's cuz
anthony mackie seemed like he was
genuinely annoyed what stop get tight
let me see what you like he is a
comedian so I thought it was just his
way of improving with ya but then the
other two were so serious it just got
lost and awkward cuz if they were
laughing then obviously it would have
been a lighter yeah both Tom Halden and
Sebastian Stan looked uncomfortable by
now anthony mackie was responding to
this situation but they were being dumb
he was funny I thought what he meant was
light-hearted but I feel like the other
two didn't get it and then didn't know
how to play long it's because when they
made a joke towards anthony mackie or
saying they don't like Falcon or
whatever or you don't know the word
friends he seemed to take real offense
because he laid down a really serious
line though about I have family like
that's a real response somehow they got
to his ego I don't know I can't imagine
what it's like to be in their shoes and
deal with fandom because what those
girls did was a representation of the
kind of society that I think kids are
growing up with when they live in a
fandom world
like YouTube comments and stuff and
Twitter comments we see offensive [ __ ]
to people you don't realize you're being
offensive to be honest the most cringy
part was them not at least having one
question my friend but at least have one
like you're getting this opportunity if
you don't even have one then you're just
embarrassing yourself because think
about how long they probably have been
up and like how early they had to use
convention they all must be so tired and
it's a QA yes question one question you
know what a kind of counteracted the
awkwardness but they just kept dishin
yeah I feel like if anyone can deal with
hate or something it could be anthony
mackie cuz he handled out like a boss
they seemed so naive to how they didn't
even know to like apologize them know
what they were saying like they think
they can just get away with saying
something mean and that's what I mean by
that growing up and like the Twitter and
YouTube common world of cool they should
just be used to hearing this so they
didn't even seem to get that what they
are saying could be offensive which is
why I think Tom Holloman Sebastian Stan
looked uncomfortable because they
weren't saying the most offensive things
you could possibly say but it was enough
to obviously provoke Anthony Mack try to
attack on top of that if he saw the
girl's face after the family comment you
could tell she was genuinely like
shaking embarrassed yeah another thing I
was like why didn't they just ask a
question that would include all of them
but at the same time if something like
that happens she probably just blanked
and like didn't know what else I'm sure
I would have loved to have been there in
that crowd at that moment though that
would have been such a for me
it's surprising I have Sebastian Stan
look so uncomfortable like why are you
so uncomfortable
because then when they had that shot of
him when she said that comment about her
being all [ __ ] yeah just kind of was
like crazy
thank you took a while to respond do you
know how to handle it well
hey man it's fun watching our favorite
superheroes and stuff get very
uncomfortable boy there's one thing this
specifically does for me seeing these
three and a panel together rumor has it
that Chris Evans is leaving Captain
America behind him he's pretty much
confirmed that but after Avengers 4 he's
done so either
Anthony Mackie or Sebastian Stan might
take up the Captain America mantle and I
would love to see these three starring
in a movie together instead of like
Spider Man and Iron Man who would be
cool to see spider-man and whoever was
Captain America at that time and the
other one friendship yeah oh you think
he's gonna be Captain America yeah yeah
alright it would be too obvious if it
was gonna be Sebastian hmm I agree let's
see if you're right salamander Sally
yeah alright guys well that was fun man
I like a boss that was great you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell more importantly
check out the salamander Sally channel
on the youtubes people it's gonna be
worth your time it's kind of worth my
time so it should be worth everyone's
time we're at the part of your Tuesday